the jurogan experience
i learned honor
from a pimp
in mississippi
when i was a kid that's a great start to
a story
[Laughter]
what did he teach you
my aunt angela
she used to take me and my cousin ricky
to the to the store and we would um get
these ice you know the little frozen ice
cigars the small ones but at this
particular store they had the giant
joints so they were like this big round
and we was good we could go get one so
my aunt
she takes me my cousin
and we're in clarksdale mississippi and
we we go to the store
and we come out
we we in the car and we're in the car
and she hadn't started the car yet she
was listening to the song and
we eat now [ __ ] he i remember this so
like it was yesterday because he had the
green one and i had the great one
and
i told him i was going to give him half
a minute for half of his just we both
had this both flavors
and as we talking
my aunt said oh [ __ ] i knew i should
have pulled off now we can't go nowhere
because these two pimps
were arguing outside the car
and we couldn't move because one of the
pimps had set his hat
on my aunt's car
she said his head on the car
and he's about him and his pimp was
arguing
and he said
man i told you don't be on my
[ __ ] side of the street with
your hoes i run in this area
and i remember the dude named bobby
bobby said you don't run the
[ __ ] thing around here
you know you don't tell bobby want to be
[ __ ]
is that
and
it stunned me
i had never heard another man call
another man a [ __ ]
or like a curse word it was all respect
mostly and they would call each other
other
names but it wouldn't be curse words him
saying so i'm
listening
and they fighting behind the side of the
street and when
bobby took his jacket off
he had a gun he had a gun host like it
was like a 38 or 32 whatever that was
they was carrying in
and his friend
he took his gun host off suit jacket
hat another dude took his hat and jack
it off they they got their girls out
there
dude that is partner and they fought
right in the middle of the street
bobby got his ass whooped
[Laughter]
bobby got
got his ass whooped out there
now
when they was
getting [ __ ] together man walked off he
gone
that dude was out there he said bobby
you should have popped his ass cause
he's the one who had the gun he said
bobby you should have popped his ass now
i remember this in detail bobby said he
put on this thing he said no
that [ __ ] won fan square
put his jacket up with his jacket on and
put his hat on he said [ __ ]
[ __ ] my goddamn nose on that
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and
i always remember that story because
just
because he had a gun
he fought that man fast squad it was
other people out there and he gave his
props after he beat him and he lost
and i'm gonna um in his mind i'm still
bobby i'm still me but i lost that one
and he beat his fan square
put his gun host back on
that's honor that's honor is that a guy
who knows how to take a loss too you got
to learn how to take a loss
the only way you do is you find out you
gotta you gotta find out
you gotta try to win and fail
and learn is that not is that not damn
to everything
damn near everything
damn everything in life everything in
life yeah you know you gotta try see
what it is if you don't if it don't work
out but don't even feel bad about
this [ __ ] not working out this is a try
but i'm not good i want to try to surf
i'm probably going to [ __ ] up every time
but
you know it's like when i was on a
mechanical board i would love to
actually bull ride
but that mechanical bull is a
[ __ ] too
and i know that some part of my neck
ain't prepared for a real animal
you